[Musique]
nous sommes le 4 octobre 2016 bienvenue
pour cette édition du 7 8 les invités
rencontres avec celles et ceux qui font
l'actualité dans le département et
aujourd'hui vous entendrez françois
simeoni c'est le nouveau président du
front national dans les yvelines après
l'éviction de son prédécesseur qui avait
affiché son soutien jean marie le pen
comment sa formation envisage les
prochaines
j'essaie échéances électorales et puis
david williams
la responsable du comité
d'administration du pga tour nous dira à
ce qu'il a pensé de cette édition de la
ryder cup aux états unis alors que dans
deux ans l événement sportif se
déroulera à saint quentin en yvelines
bonsoir françois simioni vous êtes le
tout nouveau président du fn dans les
yvelines
votre prédécesseur qui siège aussi à la
région a été écarté pour avoir soutenu
jean marie le pen en tout cas pour cette
affiche est à ses côtés lors des
manifestations de la mobilisation et
traditionnels du 1er mai quel est votre
avis sur cette situation le regard que
vous portez vous savez philippe chevrier
a été secrétaire départementale des
yvelines pendant huit ans il a fait un
excellent travail puisque je les
accompagner dans ce travail c'était
difficile je suis en 2008 qui avait plus
grand monde effectivement dans les
yvelines au front national
donc il a fait ce travail mais si vous
voulez huit ans sa fatigue savait puiser
et au bout d'un moment je pense que il
faut renouveler vous savez pas ce qu'on
lui a reprochées dans nous faire
reprocher les huit années passées à la
tête de la fédération avait écouté je
pense que c'est c'est un élément
important de la décision qui a été prise
par le bureau politique et qui ne ma
perf est absolument pas bien évidemment
enfin moi je reconnais le travail
essentiel qui a été fait par lui par
certains militants donc je ne dénigre
est vrai pas consolé ment pas philippe
chevrier lui qui se montre malgré tout
aujourd'hui un peu critique envers le
front national il se qualifie même comme
un lanceur d' alerte par rapport à la
situation que traverse le front national
sur fond de rivalité entre jean marie le
pen
ça c'est une réalité et marine le pen je
pense que vous avez à faire un parti qui
va bientôt faire 50 51% des voix aux
élections présidentielles
donc dans un parti nous l'annoncent en
un parti comme le nôtre c'est normal
qu'ils aient plusieurs tendances
effectivement c'est tout à fait logique
donc ce qui est important c'est de
rassembler le camp national et je pense
que philippe chevrier et comme d'autres
font partie du camp national donc vous
l'appelez a malgré tout vous soutenir le
reste et bien évidemment dans le camp
national de manière générale quelle que
soit la sensibilité qu'on puisse y
trouver tous ces gens-là oeuvre dans la
bonne direction
le fait qu'il y ait plusieurs
sensibilités malgré tout et qu'il y ait
toujours malgré tout cette rivalité ou
en tout cas cet antagonisme peu plus ou
moins prononcées entre jean marie le pen
historique du front national ceux qui
sont là depuis de nombreuses années et
puis puis marine le pen est ce que c'est
inquiétant pour vous pour les prochaines
élections
écoutez le fond de divisions n'y at il
pas de rivalité chez les républicains
n'y at-il pas rivalité chez les
socialistes et pourtant les rivalités
que le front national dénonce et et un
chez les socialistes passé ou chalets
républicaine des pouvoirs du pouvoir
depuis des années donc je pense que
c'est finalement très bon signe d'accord
donc ça ne vous inquiète pas absolument
pas comment se portent justement le
front national aujourd'hui vous le
disions dans tout cas dans le
département puisque vous le disiez en
2008 il y avait encore toute affaire il
ya une progression dans les inscriptions
est ce que c'est le cas encore
aujourd'hui il ya une progression énorme
actuellement il faut dire que les
événements qui se produisent
actuellement dont on va parler nous
cerles je pense que effectivement on n'a
qu'à suivre ce qui se produit au
finalement on n'a pas besoin de faire
grand chose puisque tout ce qu'on avait
annoncé depuis des années est en train
de se produire
hélas les vérifier et donc c'est
uniquement notre nos solutions qui vont
pouvoir résoudre les problèmes on va y
venir sur ses solutions juste un mot
concernant les listes pour les
législatives même si la présidentielle
arrivera avant vous y réfléchissez déjà
est ce qu'elle se destine ses listes
alors vous savez en fait comme vous
l'avez dit effectivement ce sont les
présidentielles qui l'élection
présidentielle qui est notre objectif
que les législatives ont bien sûr
décollé du résultat de l'élection
présidentielle ont bien on le prépare
bien sûr les les élections législatives
par un système de pré investiture et
nous avons sur les sur les yvelines
on y d'action près investi et
l'investiture officielle viendront plus
tard
est ce qu'il y aura un renouveau des
nouvelles têtes dans les différentes
circonscriptions
oui bien sûr parce que j'utilise mon mea
partie en mouvement changements
perpétuels donc il y aura bien sûr les
évolutions et ça n'a pas de lien avec
les divisions éventuelles au sein du
front national n'entreront pas dans la
stratégie de renouvellement il faut
renouveller les candidats et c'est ce
que vous nous expliquez vous alors vous
êtes et allez-y vous savez en fait comme
je voulais dire on est en perpétuel
mouvement
donc on rigole de nouvelles synergies
nouvelles personnes qui l'enjoignent
donc il est normal qu'on qu'on profite
de ces nouvelles compétences
vous êtes élue dans l'opposition à
versailles on vous a vue récemment dans
les différentes manifestations contre
l'installation des migrants dans le
département on voit d'ailleurs quasiment
tous les élus du front national se
mobilisaient quel que soit le
département à travers la france contre
l'arrivée des migrants pourquoi alors
écoutez c'est simple nous on est on
considère que ce ce problème donc des
migrants étaient véritablement un
problème national mais on laisse assumer
ce problème par les maires pour ça qu'on
est un soutien total avec monsieur viard
maire de l'ancienne et monsieur pommery
maire de rocquencourt vis-à-vis de la
tâche qu'on leur demande d'assumer
il est clair que cet accueil donc 2 sur
un terrain de 24 hectares de soi disant
100 personnes il faut pas se mentir ça
va être bientôt mille personnes qui vont
arriver et donc 7
cette tâche ne peut pas être réalisée
par les maires de ces communes qui sont
relativement petit
donc c'est pour ça qu'on a participé à
la réunion publique de jeudi à
l'ancienne en intervenant moi j'ai pas
pu y aller parce que j'étais en conseil
municipal à versailles mais le
secrétaire de circonscription est
intervenue il a bien signalé que nous on
soutenait le combat mais qu'il fallait
faire fallait faire attention parce que
dans la hiérarchie des républicains les
députés européens ont voté pour la
ventilation des migrants sur les dans
les pays comme en france donc pour
revenir sur l'inquiétude des maires en
tout cas au niveau local mais ça se
traduit aussi à travers les différents
différents départements
c'est de ne pas avoir été consultés
d'ailleurs quelle que soit la couleur
comme un gentil qu'on voudrait plus de
transparence
votre position est un petit peu
différente et vous me dites elles des
façons la consultation c'est parce qu'on
veut nous ne veut pas de migrants
rassembler les différentes et ça a été
cet appareil de manière claire c'est la
population qui a exprimé ce voeu pendant
les manifestations on était présent à la
manifestation division pendant cette
parler de la manifestation dimanche et
de visuels de vision effectivement parce
que ceux qui n'ont de la transparence et
ceux qui ne veulent pas du tout 2011
voilà il y avait une large partie de la
population qui a exprimé son rejet des
migrants quel que soit leur nombre et
nous on défend des effectivement cette
cette voie parce que le langage qui a
été étonné par les maires et députés
présents étaient honteux voilà il était
là pour nous faire passer la pilule nous
dire voilà on voit qu'on va en
accueillir cent il faut accueillir ces
réfugiés déjà le terme de réfugiés
moi je le dénonce donc c'était eux
pourquoi vous dénoncez au jeu de
dénoncer parce que on travaille
sémantique vous devez vous l'avez
utiliser ce terme tout à l'heure non non
et non ça c'est sion pas des réfugiés
c'est de l'immigration économique
c'était une saison des gens qui fait
aussi leur pays c'est une réalité un
aidant guerre 1% pour les syriens il ya
c'est un pur sang syrien dans cette
danse et danse migrants qui nous arrive
il ya 94 % de dôme sol il ya 73 % de
personnes qui ont moins de 25 ans c'est
pas une immigration qui je suis une
guerre c'est clairement ce repas des
familles c'est clairement une
amélioration économique voilà cette
immigration économique que l'on dénonce
depuis des années
vous savez pourquoi parce qu'elle pèse à
la baisse sur les salaires en france et
qu'elle contribue à détruire
complètement notre mode de vie en un
manque de refuser en branle en bloc
l'intégralité des migrants et des
réfugiés peu importe la sémantique
utilisée même s'il ya une réalité qui se
cache derrière est ce qu'il faudrait pas
mieux en tout cas faire faire une
évaluation de la situation aux vrais au
cas par cas et par refuser en bloc
l'arrivée total des ces populations
mais écoutez nous on n'est pas n'est pas
dans l'exécutif nous les caves des
secrétaires y arriver donc quelles sont
vos solutions les solutions
est ce qu'on refuse en bloc et on
cherche même pas à savoir qui vient et
rapports ont été greffés vous savez que
dans le programme de marine le pen est
une restriction de l'immigration à un
nombre très raisonnable je crois dix
mille personnes par an donc cette
immigration nous
nous allons clairement dire stop et
c'est ce que les gens de l'ancien grand
concours et du chenet qui était présent
dimanche attendaient ils sont partis ont
pas eu du tout ce langage là on leur a
dit vous leur a expliqué qu'il fallait
accueillir et là ça a été dit oui donc
mes propositions c'est de les refuser et
c'est aussi un moyen de faire campagne
parce qu'on y vient vous le disiez tout
à l'heure nous n'avons plus qu'à
attendre finalement parce que c'est ce
que nous prophétise ion qu'ils y
arrivent aujourd'hui ça fait partie de
votre campagne très clairement d'être
aujourd'hui présent sur le terrain bien
évidemment et mon dénonce justement les
décisions prises vous parliez tout à
l'heure de françois de mazières
françois de mazières - jeudi j'étais au
conseil municipal de verser je me posais
la question monsieur le maire signé vous
la charge la charte énoncé par steeve
briois ma commune sans milan et françois
de mazières a refusé alors qu'ils
viennent pas maintenant faire
l'hypocrite en disant qu' il défend le
combat de l'eau s'il est loin et et des
personnes de donc du début ne sais pas
s'il y aura d'autres manifestations
bien évidemment j'ai organisé cette fois
ci uniquement par le front national peut
alors on va peut-être effectivement
organiser prochainement une
manifestation sur versailles ou bien sûr
on demande à tous les patriotes de nous
rejoindre
ainsi françois simonide est revenu sur
ce plateau nouveau responsable dans le
département du front national
la 40e et 41e édition de la ryder cup la
coupe du monde du golf s'est déroulée le
week end dernier à hazeltine dans le
minnesota aux états unis c'était la
dernière édition avant celle est qui
sera organisée en septembre 2018 au golf
national de saint-quentin notre
journaliste michael et le mindoro
étaient sur place il a rencontré le
responsable du comité d'administration
du pga tour david williams
écoutez qu'est ce que vous pensez de
cette ryder cups et c'est plutôt réussi
ces excellents the temper rouge pour moi
dans le score est aussi le pack ou et
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la team
europe
c'est une excellente équipe
quand mes joues du monde et que pensez
vous de l'organisation générale de la
ryder cup c'est vraiment une grosse
organisation cette année non il est très
très bien organisés et l'équipage hawtin
a fait un très très bon travail et en
france il y aura la ryder cup du coup
dans deux ans que pensez vous de cette
ryder cup y aller prête déjà ah oui oui
on a deux ans avant de commencer il est
un bouc de faire mais je pense que tout
va bien dans deux ans et vous pensez que
le public répondra présent dans deux ans
ouais j'espère j'espère quand le rugby
et le foot les français aiment beaucoup
les sports j'espère que les français est
ma plus le goff temps deux ans et
l'europe a besoin
la team europe a besoin d'avoir une
équipe soudée et d'avoir un public de
feu en 2018 pour remporter la victoire
bon j'espère que la radio capp team des
vieux rock dans deux ans à des joueurs
français aussi un très important et vous
attendait beaucoup du public en 2018 qui
est une grosse ambiance pour pousser les
joueurs
oui oui pour nous le très joueur ayant
la douze joueurs dont l'équipe mais avec
tous les gens là ces 13 vous avez un
petit mot pour les français obama nous
sommes très heureux de leur handicap à
paris est difficile d'attendre deux en
un
nous pensons que le jeu aura très bien
là rendez vous en 2018 donc oui merci
beaucoup david williams merci beaucoup
c'est la fin de cette édition rendez
vous demain mercredi avec un nouveau 7 8
ans vite et il sera question de la
primaire à droite le primaire des
républicains avec keith david douillet
également et il sera question de la fête
du vélo dans les yvelines et puis du
yarn bombing le mobilier urbain à
maurepas sera recouvert de tricot durant
tout le mois d'octobre une opération
pour le moins originale toutes les
explications demain merci de nous avoir
suivis
[Musique]